terrible frayeur que vous êtes remise en
mémoire à travers cette redécouverte de
méthode
et puis donc la pièce de kiki van
beethoven interprété par daniel le brun
subir de la maurienne donc tous ces
rôles merci à vous et pour toutes celles
et ceux d'entre vous qui souhaitez
retrouver les propos de frédéric salat
baroux et de eric emmanuel schmitt
rendez vous évidemment à tout moment sur
publicsenat.fr
un animateur bienvenue dans ce nouveau
rendez vous sur public sénat tous au
vert des initiatives écolos je fabrique
ma propre éolienne ou comment rendre
l'énergie du vent accessible et bien à
tous un stage proposé par une petite
entreprise vous allez le voir
tous au vert c'est une nouvelle émission
écolo présenté par samuel etienne jeudi
à 18h sur de big sénat
voilà bienvenue à tous pour une journée
spéciale à vivre sur les chaînes
parlementaires le jour du vote du vote
solennel du vote définitif du projet de
loi sur les retraites après la réunion
d'hier de la commission mixte paritaire
c'est à dire du groupe commun de députés
et de sénateurs qui se sont mis d'accord
sur un texte unique qui va donc être
voté dans les mêmes termes d'abord par
le sénat puis probablement en fin de
soirée par l'assemblée nationale après
quoi après quoi le projet de loi sur les
retraites en discussion depuis de longs
mois maintenant sera définitivement
adopté la retraite l'âge légal de la
retraite passera en france à 62 ans avec
tout de même une dernière étape à
franchir avant que la loi ne puisse être
promulguée par le président de la
république
on le sait depuis ce matin le parti
socialiste les parlementaires ps ont
décidé de déposer un recours devant le
conseil constitutionnel
information publiée d'ailleurs ce matin
en avant première sur le site internet
de public sénat publicsenat.fr
un recours donc qui devrait retarder
d'une quinzaine de jours la promulgation
de la loi qui pourrait donc avoir lieu à
la mi novembre mais avant cela ce que
vous allez vivre cet après midi ce sont
les dernières étapes avec le débat qui
va reprendre dans un instant sur le
texte issu de la commission mixte
paritaire dont je vous parlais ce matin
vous avez pu vivre des échanges assez
vifs en fin de matinée entre la majorité
et l'opposition notamment le parti les
sénateurs socialistes et eric woerth le
ministre du travail et la séance
présidée par gérard larcher le président
du sénat s'est interrompue avant les
toutes dernières explications de vote
dont vous allez suivre le début tout de
suite en direct chacun des groupes à
pouvoir donc s'exprimer pour un dernier
baroud d'honneur si je puis dire sur ce
projet de loi après plus de 120 heures
de débat ici au sénat quasiment trois
semaines donc de débats sur ce projet
sur les retraites à 15h nous
retrouverons l'assemblée nationale pour
la science des questions d'actualité et
le vote solennel vous le vivre et en
direct sur les chaînes parlementaires à
partir de 16h voilà pour ce menu très
chargé
nous allons tout de suite rejoindre les
bancs de l'hémicycle dans quelques
instants pour suivre ce débat a noté la
foule des grands jours au sénat bien sûr
les sénateurs sont là pour ce vote
solennel beaucoup beaucoup de sénateurs
présents dans l'hémicycle cet après midi
à noter aussi que le sénat est
quadrillée par des cars de crs puisqu'il
est une manifestation de l'unef devant
le sénat et donc le lac c'est même au
sénat est barrée pour ne pas perturber
le vote de ses doigts donc une ambiance
malgré tout assez tendue que ce soit
dans l'hémicycle le ton entre la
majorité et l'opposition
et puis hors de l'hémicycle devant le
sénat où les manifestants n'ont pas
encore perdu espoir de faire bouger les
choses voilà tout de suite
à suivre à vivre en direct les dernières
explications de vote avant le vote du
projet de loi sur les retraites
paru aux explications de vote et au vote
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi
dans l'arrêt des actions telles qu'elles
résultent du texte proposé par la
commission mixte paritaire pour les
explications de vote
la parole est à monsieur jean pierre bel
président du groupe socialiste
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président
merci monsieur le président ce président
monsieur les monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous voici arrivés à
l'heure du vote solennel sur votre
projet de loi relatif aux retraites
ce sera donc avec solennité que je vais
m'adresser à vous cet après midi depuis
le premier jour nous n'avons cessé de
dénoncer d'argumenter et de proposer
mais aujourd'hui je m'en tiendrai à
l'essentiel cette loi est injuste elle
fait reposer l'effort tout l'effort sur
celles et ceux qui donnent déjà temps et
qui demain souffrir en plus encore sur
le président monsieur le ministre votre
projet de loi l'attitude du gouvernement
et du président de la république au
cours des dernières semaines a fait
trois victimes
la première victime bien sûr ce sont les
françaises et les français leur
mobilisation
répétez massive le démontre ils ne
veulent pas de la réforme que vous leur
proposez
ce sont eux qui vont être touchés par
notre texte de loi qualifié par un
membre de votre gouvernement
quel aveu de régression sociale en
procédant ainsi vous avez fait au
passage une deuxième victime monsieur le
ministre depuis 2007
vous avez tué l'idée même de réforme
lorsque nicolas sarkozy a été élu à la
présidence de la république en 2007
il existait alors l'idée qu'une réforme
a pour objet d'améliorer la vie des gens
la vie de ce que nous représentons
mais depuis qu avez vous fait
qu'allait-il cette idée de progrès vous
avez mis en place le bouclier fiscal qui
protège les amis du fouquet's épargne
grandement les hauts revenus et les
grandes fortunes
les capitaux spéculatifs vous avez voté
un plan de relance qui injecte de
l'argent public dans les banques sans
demander la moindre le moindre
engagement en contrepartie face à votre
échec en matière de politique économique
et sociale vous avez identifié des boucs
émissaires faciles en particulier les
élus locaux et leur collectivité mais
surtout les plus fragiles ceux qui ont
du mal à se défendre en concentrant sur
eux
la brutalité de vos paroles et de vos
actes comme si cela a apporté la moindre
solution concrète aux maux de notre pays
comme si c'était une attitude digne
d'une grande république
et puis cerise sur le gâteau vous avez
engagé le projet de loi sur les
retraites qui vous était commanditée par
le patronat on l'a vu hier encore à la
télévision où madame parisot a dicté la
ligne de conduite à tenir sur les
seniors et sur les jeunes
aussitôt approuvée par le ministre
présent et ce faisant et ce faisant vous
avez fait votre troisième victime
vous avez abîmé notre république et
notre démocratie
vous avez engagé la réforme sans mandat
c'est un reniement de la parole d'état
une attaque inouï à la conception que
nous avons de notre démocratie
vous êtes privés d'un véritable échange
avec les partenaires sociaux
c'est un bien mauvais coup porté à notre
démocratie sociale
tous les syndicats confirmeront
qu'aucune négociation collective digne
de ce nom n'a eu lieu toutes les
ouvertures paraît de fait sont restés
sans réponse toutes les demandes de
dialogue social sont restées lettre
morte
enfin vous avez engagé ce projet de loi
en considérant que le parlement devait
se plier à vos impératifs de temps et de
calendrier ce faisant vous avez mépriser
notre démocratie parlementaire
pourtant les effets d'annoncé dont
pendant qu'ils aient souvenez-vous au
début de nos travaux que n'at-on entendu
il y aurait du temps pour le débat les
débats ont été interrompues à
l'assemblée nationale perturbé censuré
au sénat où l'ordre du jour a été
modifié
au gré des desiderata de l'elysée le
débat serait transparent vous n'avez eu
de cesse de priver nos concitoyens d'un
débat clair en assénant que nous
n'avions pas de projet alternatif au
moment même où vous nous empêcher de le
présenter devant notre assemblée et où
vous n'aviez de cesse que de dénoncer
nos propositions étrange paradoxe nous
avait dit le sénat sera respectée vous
en aviez vous même pris publiquement
l'engagement monsieur le président mais
ne nous racontons pas d'histoire il a
été désavoué tout au long de cette
séquence
car à quoi sert notre prétendue
indépendance d'esprit
si notre ordre du jour pardon est fixé à
l'elysée où est le respect du sénat
lorsque le gouvernement décrète le
recours aux 44 3 qui met un terme à nos
débats est ce que nos travaux doivent
être calqué sur la stratégie de
communication de l'elysée ou sur les
impératifs de calendrier du président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues vous avez
cru pu voir pouvoir vous exprimer en
parlant à propos de ce texte je les lui
du syndrome du dentiste mais je vous le
dis ce projet de loi fera du mal et le
mal sera durable
la manière dont le gouvernement a
conduit les débats laissera des traces
nous nous sommes employés à faire
entendre notre voix et a présenté un
autre projet pour ce qui nous concerne
nous allons nous tourner à nouveau vers
les partenaires sociaux vers les
français pour tes pour débattre ensemble
de notre projet de nos propositions sur
ce sujet comme sur d'autres
car il appartient à ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont opposés à votre funeste politique
de construire l'alternative d'offrir une
espérance de dire à tous qu'il n'ya pas
de fatalité à la régression que le
mépris n'aura qu'un temps qu ensemble
nous retrouvons nous nous retrouverons
pour tracer un autre chemin car c'est
notre responsabilité c'est notre fierté
c'est notre honneur
oui mes chers collègues pour nous
aujourd'hui comme demain un seul
objectif un seul chemin un seul cap
rendre l'espoir aux français je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole
est maintenant au président yvan kohler
président du groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen parole
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous sommes arrivés au bout
d'un débat qui nous aura mobilisé durant
trois semaines
bien souvent de jour bien souvent de
nuit ses quelque 140 heures consacrée au
projet de loi portant réforme des
retraites resteront gravés dans les
annales de l'histoire parlementaire
néanmoins sur un sujet majeur
nous aurions dû débattre davantage si
dans sa dernière ligne droite
le débat n'a vait été faussée pour ne
pas dire censuré je voulais dit monsieur
le ministre la semaine dernière je me
permets de le répéter le recours au vote
bloqué est et restera comme une faute
politique sur cette réforme
et cet épisode et cet épisode
parlementaire de cet épisode
parlementaire nous retiendrons un texte
voulu à tout prix parents gouvernement
resté insensible aux attentes de
millions de français qui sont descendus
dans la rue pour dénoncer haut et fort
la justice de cette réforme
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement
commet une grave erreur de gouvernance
elle s'attend à faire passer coûte que
coûte une réforme présentée comme
arithmétique alors que dogmatique une
réforme présentée comme négocier alors
qu imposer d'ailleurs le seul ministre
bien avant que la rue une grande colère
bien avant que les français ne
manifestent nous étions nombreux ici à
avoir alerté le gouvernement sur le
danger de
extrait qui ne ferait pas l'objet d'un
consensus républicain
moi même le 19 février dernier lors des
questions d'actualité j'avais interpellé
monsieur le premier ministre pour lui
dire que les réformes ne se font jamais
contre les français mais avec eux et que
plusieurs de ses prédécesseurs l'avaient
appris à leurs dépens je rappellerai
aussi qu'à cette époque que le président
de la république
souvenons nous s'était engagé à l'issue
du sommet social à refuser tout recours
au passage en force nous gouverner ce
n'est pas pratique et l'autoritarisme
diriger c'est conduire un peuple avec
son assentiment et ce texte
et c'est son défaut majeur est aux
antipodes du consensus républicain
alors que le principe d'une réforme
était acceptée admis par la majorité de
nos concitoyens vous avez réussi par des
dispositifs faisant des salariés la
seule variable d'ajustement
vous avez réussi à déclencher un rejet
généralisé quant à la promesse
présidentielle du 15 février 2010 de ne
pas bloquer les débats
elle a depuis nous en sommes aperçus
volé en éclats
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire du
règlement méprisé l'assemblée nationale
on vote unique décidé jeudi dernier pour
le sénat le passage en force a bel et
bien été imposée au parlement
et le comble c'est que l'article 44-3 a
été dégainée au moment de l'examen des
articles additionnels des articles qui
aurait permis à l'opposition de défendre
ses propositions dont vous avez toujours
nié l'existence et il est certain
monsieur le ministre que vous avez tout
fait pour les étouffer
parce qu'au fond vous savez qu'une autre
voie est possible
et si vous en aviez
donnez l'occasion oui nous aurions pu
exposer d'autres pistes des pistes qui
tenait réellement compte des carrières
bloqué de la pénibilité de la question
des femmes du handicap
certes c'est vrai vous avez fait un pas
en direction du système de retraite à
points auxquels le r d sur des radicaux
était particulièrement attaché
une avancée qui vous a fait d'ailleurs
reconnaître implicitement sans doute
qu'il existait donc bien d'autres
alternatives au relèvement de l'âge de
la retraite
mes chers collègues quand il était
encore temps de rechercher ce consensus
républicain dont je vous parlais à
l'instant j'ai demandé avec mes
collègues présidents de groupe crc
socialiste une suspension des débats à
la suite de cela monsieur le ministre
vous avez répondu suspendre
quelle drôle d'idée portait il me semble
que les drôles d'idées monsieur le
ministre vous appartiennent en effet
n'est ce pas une drôle d'idée que de
reporter l'essentiel du poids de la
réforme sur les salariés car les
dividendes progressent toujours plus
sans être fiscalement inquiété quelle
drôle d'idée aussi de demander à ceux
qui ont des métiers pénibles de
travailler plus
quelle drôle d'idée de récompenser des
salariés qui ont commencé tôt à leur
demandant de travailler plus longtemps
est enfin sur la réforme sur la réforme
quelle drôle d'idée de brandir le vote
unique sur un texte dans les enjeux
exigé le débat le plus démocratique
possible
vous le voyez bien monsieur le ministre
c'est votre gouvernement qui a de drôles
d'idées de mauvaise idée l'opposition
nous l'a démontré les français voulons
dit vous n'avez visiblement pas tout
entendu
en conséquence les radicaux de gauche et
la grande majorité du rdse ne voteront
pas cette réforme des retraites
merci la parole est maintenant président
fischer par là même la présidente nicole
borvo pardonnez moi pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen sénateurs
du parti de gauche pardonnez moi même la
présidente la parole la présidente
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez fait preuve d'une
remarquable constance droit dans vos
bottes
vous avez répété inlassablement que
votre réforme était la seule possible
pour combler le déficit du régime des
retraites c'est un mensonge
nous vous avons proposé de faire cotiser
les revenus financiers au même taux que
les revenus du travail
vous refusez le débat vous avait martelé
que cette réforme était juste c'est un
mensonge
elle repose à 85% sur les salaires et
encore davantage sur les plus modestes
d'entre ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt et qui vont cotiser
jusqu'à 44 ans pour avoir la retraite et
la paieront davantage sur les femmes qui
pendant longtemps encore seront
discriminés dans la carrière
professionnelle
vous savez martelé que vous preniez en
compte la pénibilité c'est un mensonge
vous avez refusé tout débat sur la
pénibilité des métiers et transformer la
pénibilité en invalidité individuel vous
avait martelé que vous avez sauvé les
retraites par répartition c'est un
mensonge
rien n'est réglé après 2018 et vous avez
même acte est de faire une réforme
systémique dès 2013 la vérité a été
rétablie clairement par madame parisot
hier dans les médias où elle est apparue
rayonnante elle a tenu à le dire quelle
était la marraine de cette réforme je
vous l'avais déjà rappelé
je vous l'avais déjà rappelé si le
président de la république à renier son
engagement de 2007 de ne pas porter
atteinte à la retraite à 60 ans le medef
avait publié en 2007 le véritable
programme de la droite en finir avec la
retraite à 60 ans est allé vers la
retraite par capitalisation
madame parisot se félicite du résultat
et vous félicite
il est bien clair que votre gouvernement
et votre majorité ne veut toucher à
aucun privilège de ceux qui engrange des
dividendes ce qui bénéficie de stock
options ce qui touche les retraites
chapeaux ceux qui bénéficient de niches
fiscales et honte et ceux qui
bénéficient du bouclier fiscal
une chose est tout aussi clair c'est que
votre gouvernement et votre majorité
veut faire payer aux salariés et à le
seul ceux qui ont déjà payé la crise
financière provoquée par les premiers ce
que je viens de citer
et que vous voulez leur faire payer
maintenant votre réforme des retraites
voilà la réalité monsieur le ministre
l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens
sont contre votre réforme ils le sont
parce qu'ils l'ont très bien compris
qu'elle était injuste
ils ont très bien compris qu'il est
ils savent qu'il est scandaleux de
repousser l'âge de la retraite quand des
millions de salariés sont écartés du
marché du travail par le patronat bien
avant 60 ans parce que ils savent qu'on
ne peut pas exercer de métiers pénibles
au delà de 60 ans et même avant
parce qu'ils savent que repousser l'âge
de la retraite c'est retarder l'entrée
des jeunes au travail
la jeunesse l'a bien compris et vos
dénégations sur le sujet n'y changera
rien
ils changeront rien pardo parce qu'ils
savent que votre politique c'est
toujours plus pour la france d'en haut
toujours moins pour la france d'en bas
vous invoquez vous invoquez la
légitimité du parlement
oui le parlement est légitime et c'est
la raison pour laquelle ils ne méritent
pas que vous l'ayez malmené depuis le
début de la discussion parlementaire
mais quand le gouvernement et sa
majorité sur dans un tel décalage avec
le peuple
le bon fonctionnement de nos
institutions devraient permettre de
statuer
notre système actuel les verrouille les
institutions mais les politiques ont
toujours la possibilité d'entendre et de
prendre des décisions vous devez
répondre aux organisations syndicales et
à nos concitoyens aient accepté d'ouvrir
un véritable dialogue sur l'ensemble des
paramètres d'une réforme des retraites
vous ne voulez rien entendre vous
répondez par la provocation
monsieur le ministre nous voterons
contre votre réforme parce que nous
voulons la justice sociale la solidarité
nationale et nous voulons qu'il soit mis
fin aux privilèges exorbitants de
quelques-uns je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant président
gérard longuet président de l'union du
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
groupe ump avec conviction votre à les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire le groupe ump votera avec
conviction ces conclusions parce que
nous avons la certitude monsieur le
ministre que votre loi est à la fois
forte et juste et j'utilise ces deux
mots chers collègues et les justes parce
qu'elle sauve le régime de retraite par
répartition et les fortes parce que
c'est la seule loi qui sont
effectivement dans le contexte
économique d'aujourd'hui ce régime juste
des retraites par répartition nous nous
sommes vus ni naturellement par le
masochisme c'est à dire le plaisir
solitaire de s'opposer à tout le monde
ni même chers collègues de gauche par la
cruauté car nous connaissons
parfaitement le monde du travail que
nous représentons autant que vous
mais nous avons nous avons ce dont vous
avez peu fait preuve par le passé nous
avons le sens de la responsabilité
collective des élus au regard de 64
millions de français qui ont le droit de
savoir si leur régime de retraite pourra
en effet continuer de fonctionner ici
dans cette assemblée
nous avons une compétence forte parce
que la mission d'évaluation et de
contrôle de la sécurité sociale à trois
reprises à présenter des rapports de
fonds depuis plusieurs années rapport de
fond qui tirait le signal d'alarmé
vous apportez une réponse monsieur le
ministre que vos prédécesseurs en 1982
n'avait même pas esquissé car il avait
refusé au parlement un débat sur la
retraite à 60 ans de peur de faire
apparaître leurs propres contradictions
c'est un devoir absolu c'est un devoir
absolu qui en effet je le reconnais
n'était pas à l'ordre du jour de prod du
pourquoi ne s'est-il pas parce que nous
avions à l'époque après le signal
d'alarmé justement tiré par michel
rocard en 1991
si j'avais le compteur ce serait mieux
non ils marchent pas nous avions le
signal d'alarmé tiré en 1991 par michel
rocard et nous avions nous y avions
répondu dès 1993 avec edouard balladur
et en 2003 mais c'est le premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin avec
françois fillon
mais ce qui n'était pas à l'ordre du
jour de 2007 s'est imposé avec la crise
de 2008 et que vous le vouliez ou non
premier devoir d'un gouvernement c'est
de faire face aux obstacles que
rencontrent une communauté et qui
manifestement ne pouvait pas méconnaître
cette évidence la crise économique a
accéléré de 20 ans les rendez vous
financier de notre régime de retraite
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avions à devoir absolu d'apporter une
réponse et monsieur le ministre votre
loi le permet le travail parlementaire
ici au sénat était non il a été
intéressant il a été fructueux
il a été riche il nous a permis de faire
progresser le texte issu de l'assemblée
nationale et je constate avec plaisir
que la commission mixte paritaire
comme nous en avions pris l'engagement
devant l'ensemble des collègues a repris
l'essentiel des amendements de votre
haute assemblée pour enrichir ce texte
et répondre à des questions précises sur
les mères de famille sur la pénibilité
sur les chômeurs de longue durée sur les
parents handicapés un cycle sur les
travailleurs handicapés nous avons même
utilement progresser sur la médecine du
travail même si monsieur le rapporteur
notre objectif d'alterner les
présidences des services de médecine de
travail n'a pas été en définitive
retenue nous avons fait un travail utile
ce travail utile soutien appuyé et
conforte le devoir absolu que vous avez
agi mais monsieur le ministre d'apporter
à nos compatriotes une réponse de court
terme aux besoins
à la question simple le régime des
retraites par répartition peut-il
fonctionner ces prochaines années
grâce à vous grâce à vos monsieur le
ministre la réponse devant l'opinion
publique devant 64 millions de français
concernés qu'il soit actif retraité aux
parents des uns et des autres est
manifestement oui je voudrais terminer
par cet amendement dont jeu qui pour moi
revêt une importance fondamentale c'est
en effet dans les articles additionnels
les amendements fusionnée qui ont permis
de mettre en place ce rendez vous sur le
rendez-vous systémique de 2003 une seule
formule est ce que vous craignez le
débat avez vous peur d'affronter les
réalités
mais connaissez vous les grands systèmes
qui commande les régimes de retraite en
europe et dans le monde
pourquoi diable craignez vous ce rendez
vous nous avons l'ambition ensemble
d'apporter une réponse durable aux
régimes de retraite par répartition et
ce rendez-vous de 2003 est un grand
rendez vous possible parce que vous avez
sauvé à l'instant un régime auquel nos
compatriotes sont attachés
merci monsieur le président vous venez
de suivre le début de ces explications
de vote vous l'avez vu avec une ambiance
assez vivace étendu dans l'hémicycle du
sénat
c'était à l'instant même le président du
groupe ump très applaudi par son groupe
le sénateur et ancien ministre gérard
longuet qui a défendu ce projet de
réforme des retraites vous avez entendu
aussi les critiques de la présidente du
groupe est un peu difficile j'ai
l'impression la passion et dans cette
salle monsieur le président sur les
ministres mes chers collègues nous
sommes arrivés au bout d'un long débat
passionné on vient encore de le voir
passionnel aussi je crois que tout a été
dit et redit mme hatem made man x
essayons pour notre part d'en faire un
rapide bilan depuis la publication du
projet de réforme des retraites le
groupe centriste a approuvé sa mesure
principale le report de la borne d'âge
de 60 à 62 ans sous réserve de
l'aménager pour les carrières longues et
de réduire un certain nombre
d'injustices et d'inégalités du système
le groupe refusé ainsi le passage